Salut romain... ça va toi ? T'as l'air tout raide.
Le coup je veux dire. Je suis allé à un concert de métal hier.
Et donc ? J'ai fait un truc avec la tête là et je suis tout coincé. Ah ok...
Chose promise chose due c'est aujourd'hui la toute première vidéo de notre série highway to hell fest qui va vous aider à préparer au mieux
votre festival de l'été. On commence par une activité bien spécifique et incontournable du genre le head banging
"J'suis sur l'autoroute pour le hell fest !"
Alors le headbanging pour celles et ceux qui ne connaîtraient pas c'est, disons une danse mais qui se pratique
essentiellement avec la tête
et les cheveux. Alors il y a plusieurs écoles, il y a même une multitude de techniques mais globalement ça consiste à bouger la tête
plus ou moins rapidement et plus ou moins violemment au rythme de la musique.
On peut faire ça d'avant en arrière,
sur les côtés,
en faisant des cercles ou... un peu comme on veut.
C'est une activité physique que je qualifierais d'à la fois artistique et sportive
donc c'est hyper important de bien se préparer pour être le plus performant possible
et aussi pour éviter
la blessure. Je vous arrête tout de suite parce que je vous vois venir, vous allez me parler de cet allemand de 50 ans qui
a fait un hématome cérébral après un concert de motörhead
C'est ce que vous allez faire c'est ça ? Bon... ne le faites pas.
bon alors oui, les médecins ont dit que c'était probablement lié au headbanging
parce que le cerveau, quand il bouge dans tous les sens comme ça, il peut se cogner contre la boîte crânienne
et les médecins estiment que c'est peut-être ce qui l'a fait saigner. Mais qu'on soit bien d'accord, ce pauvre homme il avait probablement
déjà une fragilité à ce niveau là et c'est rarissime comme cas.
C'est comme la jeune fille de 24 ans qui a fait une rupture d'anévrisme en se masturbant et puis on en a parlé dans une
vidéo précédente mais les footballeurs ils peuvent aussi
s'abîmer le cerveau en faisant des têtes. Bon mais on n'interdit ni le foot ni l'orgasme à priori donc
laissez nous "headbanguer" tranquilles, par pitié. Mais ceci étant dit c'est vrai que des mouvements répétés comme ça, rapides, violents
c'est comme tous les sports extrêmes, c'est pas sans danger dans l'absolu.
D'ailleurs Tom Araya le bassiste chanteur de Slayer, pour les noobs... Tom Araya donc, qui était un des champions de la discipline
eh ben il a été opéré des cervicales
et depuis il est privé de headbanging. Il n'est pas le seul à s'être bousillé le coup, il y a aussi Jason Newsted
l'ancien bassiste de metallica et Mick Thomson
le guitariste de slipknot. Vous imaginez bien que si les pros ont ce genre de problème ça peut aussi vous arriver.
Sauf ! Que je suis là...
et je vais vous donner deux ou trois conseils pour pouvoir "headbanguer" à loisir, sans danger et profiter du hellfest
jusqu'au bout et profiter de tous les autres concerts auxquels vous irez ensuite;
et de vos cervicales.
Alors les risques ! Ça va des douleurs musculaires au niveau du cou et du dos, parce qu'il est concerné aussi,
jusqu'au coup du lapin. Et vous savez comment on dit coup du lapin en anglais ? "whiplash!"
Whiplash exactement ! Merci james et c'est marrant parce que c'est aussi le nom d'un style de headbanging, bon mais alors comment on fait pour "headbanguer"
tranquille ? D'abord les conseils de base:
plus votre corps est fatigué moins il encaisse donc, dormez... un peu.
et du coup si vous êtes au camping pensez à prendre des bouchons d'oreilles.
Faites des pauses de temps en temps "headbanguez" pas pendant 72 heures non-stop. Deuxième conseil : comme tout bon sportif:
hydratez-vous.
Alors non!...L'alcool ça déshydrate, l'eau: ça hydrate! donc buvez de l'eau, ok pas que de l'eau hein...
On est en festival, je suis pas une bête ! Mais entre deux bières
pensez à en boire un petit peu,
en plus ça évite la gueule de bois. Et le conseil technique maintenant :
Le style de headbanging le moins à même de vous causer des soucis c'est le full body, en gros les deux pieds plantés dans le sol
les genoux un peu pliés et c'est tout le corps qui bouge
pas juste le cou. C'est comme une grande vague qui part d'en bas et qui se termine au bout des cheveux .... enfin pour ceux qui en ont...
Du coup l'effort est réparti et c'est pas que le coup qui encaisse...Astuce.
Voilà les trois petits trucs que je peux vous donner pour quand vous serez sur place, mais comme on l'a vu
le plus important c'est de bien se préparer.
Alors voilà quelques exercices que m'a conseillé une kiné dont je vous mets les coordonnées dans la description si ça vous intéresse
et que vous pouvez faire chez vous. Le but c'est de renforcer vos muscles pour bien stabiliser votre carcasse.
On commence par la correction posturale.
On a tendance à être un peu avachi comme ça, on va corriger tout ça avec un exercice très simple : vous mettez vos omoplates
vers l'arrière et vers le bas, vous bombez un peu le torse, vous rentrez le menton un peu, pas trop.
Vous vous grandissez en tirant le sommet du crâne vers le haut,
toujours en regardant droit devant vous. Voilà et vous tenez comme ça pendant 5 secondes,
vous relâchez
et vous recommencez. Voilà donc ça c'est la position de base dans laquelle il faudra faire tous les autres exercices, maintenant on va renforcer les
muscles qui stabilisent votre cou. Pour ça vous vous mettez contre un mur
avec un petit coussin coquet derrière la tête
sauf s'il n'y a pas la place évidemment et là pareil, vous mettez vos omoplates vers l'arrière vers le bas, vous rentrez le menton un
peu, pas trop et vous enfoncez le coussin
derrière votre tête. Vous faites des petites séries de cinq secondes.
Voilà ça c'est pour les stabilisateurs du cou, maintenant on va s'occuper de la mobilité de votre thorax.
Ce coup-là vous mettez les mains derrière la tête, vous
écartez bien les coudes et puis vous les rapprochez, voilà comme ça et vous recommencez ça plusieurs fois.
Ensuite vous tirez les bras vers l'avant puis vous les étirez en croix,
les paumes de main vers l'avant, toujours le regard au loin. On termine pour le haut du corps avec un petit exercice de renforcement musculaire
hyper simple. Alors on commence par corriger sa posture comme dans le premier exercice :
omoplates vers l'arrière, torse bombé
double menton mais pas trop, on se grandit en tirant le haut du crâne
et là vous mettez votre main à plat contre votre front et vous poussez contre la main
sans plier le cou en gardant la position de départ, pareil en arrière et de chaque côté.
Voilà, et vous refaites plusieurs séries. Et pour gainer l'ensemble on se fait un petit exercice qui concerne les abdos et les muscles profonds
que vous connaissez certainement
la planche. Là vous vous mettez sur les avant-bras les coudes à angle droit et sur la pointe des pieds.
Attention le dos doit être bien droit, pour être sûr vous pouvez poser un objet dessus; s'il reste en place
c'est bon, s'il tombe c'est pas bon.
Vous regardez toujours droit devant vous, c'est à dire pour le coup le sol
et vous tenez la position.
Alors au début ça va être compliqué mais rapidement vous allez pouvoir monter à 30 secondes voire une minute
et là pareil vous enchaînez les séries avec un peu de repos entre chaque. Voilà vous pouvez commencer à essayer tout ça
devant un miroir pour être sûr de faire les bons mouvements mais un mois avant le hellfest, l'idéal c'est d'intensifier
et de faire ça dix minutes tous les jours. Bon maintenant vous avez votre petit programme de trading perso mais
je peux pas vous laisser comme ça, sans deux trois conseils pour le jour de la compète. Le secret des champions,
celui qui permet d'être à la fois performant et d'éviter les blessures
c'est ?
C'est ? Le dopage !
L'échauffement
et les étirements. Avant de filer vous secouer dans la fosse : petit échauffement des cervicales
en douceur, alors vous faites des demi cercles vers l'avant puis vers l'arrière
tranquillement
et vous pouvez aussi refaire l'exercice
thoracique, vous savez celui avec les mains derrière la tête et les coudes qui se serrent et qui s'écartent. Et le lendemain matin
après la douche, enfin si vous en prenez une hein... parce que des fois il y a la queue mais bon c'est pas la question;
pour s'étirer le coup vous baissez l'épaule bien bas
vous essayez de poser l'oreille sur l'épaule et vous tenez 20 secondes de chaque côté. Puis pareil vers l'avant,
menton rentré et vers l'arrière en tirant le menton vers le haut
On va dire que les étirements vous les faites le lendemain hein ?
Le soir vous avez quartier libre. Alors si malgré ça vous avez des PETITS soucis, des petits hein ?
Vous pouvez avoir prévu d'emmener avec vous de la pommade type baume saint bernard,
decontractyl ou celle que vous conseillera votre pharmacien ou votre médecin.
Mais surtout pour ça comme pour tout le reste,
ça me donne l'occasion de vous rappeler un truc : sur le site du hellfest il y a des secouristes, des médecins, des infirmiers donc en cas
de vrai(s) problème(s) faites leur signe. Et oui parce que DTC c'est fini pour aujourd'hui,
on se retrouve donc très bientôt pour une prochaine vidéo, d'ici là mettez -vous bien et surtout portez-vous bien.